today I'll stick to football just a solo
show today our guy Connor out with a
little bit of food poisoning we don't
know what happened on South Beach last
night but thoughts and prayers to Connor
something at the heat game I guess got
him a little sick he hopefully will be
back on Thursday when we have a ton of
interviews lined up with today's to me
me running through a lot of the draft
news and gonna be joined by Penn State
pass rusher yeech or gross macho
somebody really excited to talk to a guy
who's overcome a ton to get to this
point where now he's one of the premier
draft prospects in the country I want to
remind everybody though this Saturday
February 1st we actually a really busy
day here at stick to football at 1:00
p.m. we're gonna be hosting an event
with special guest Kenny Vaccaro safety
for the Tennessee Titans a Texas guy so
you know Mello and I are gonna be really
excited to talk to Kenny good talk to
him about how do you tackle Derrick
Henry how what does Ryan Tannehill mean
to this team a lot of you know Mike
Vrabel stories this can be a good time
and it's actually open to the public so
you check that out it's it one one one
one so double 11 Lincoln Road here in
Miami Beach Florida it's definitely
gonna be a good time and then that
evening hopefully you've seen us posting
about this we are actually going to be
co-hosting an event in downtown Fort
Lauderdale they're taking over 25 bars
three city blocks close to traffic
Chiefs fans are basically invading Fort
Lauderdale so myself Melo Connor will be
there a lot of special guests dante hall
tomba holly it's gonna be a good time
it's free to the public there were some
VIP passes that sold out but it's free
so you come down they're gonna have
merch for sale Boulevard beer to drink
all those great things so it's like an
extension of the tailgate tour basically
and I'm gonna I'm just gonna be talking
to the the video guys here today I don't
have any wants to talk to you so Jorge
Matty hope you're ready we're gonna have
some conversations guys get a microphone
ready let's start things off right here
though the Cleveland Browns
maybe this shouldn't be a surprise to us
but we woke up the Cleveland Browns and
ones get firing people
alonzo highsmith who's been in the NFL
forever played college football at the
University of Miami has been everywhere
highly respected guy who came up with
the Green Bay Packers there was talk
that at one point he would be a GM well
he goes to Cleveland with John Dorsey
a couple years ago and becomes a
high-level Scout there
Alonzo Highsmith fired this morning by
the Cleveland Browns once Andrew Berry
came in as the new general manager and
there's speculation that elliott wolf
could also be fired now these are two
league blueblood names when it comes to
scouting in the NFL
Elliott Wolves dad Ron
wolf is one of the if you're gonna make
a Mount Rushmore of scouts you probably
are putting Ron and Wolf on there a guy
who really built the Green Bay Packers
in the Brett Favre era literally wrote
the book on team building it's called
the Packer way definitely recommend
picking that up my copy is so like
dog-eared and and marked up with notes
that I actually need to get a new one
so with Ron wolf son Elliott now out and
with alonzo highsmith out the Browns are
kind of put in this situation where they
don't have any true what I would call
traditional scouts in the front office
and I tweeted this Wednesday morning and
a lot of people got really upset at me
because they said well Andrew berry the
GM is the scout and I want to clarify
here on the podcast we have some time to
do that why I say he's not a traditional
Scout and I actually reached out to a
couple people who have worked with
Andrew berry this morning just to make
sure that my memory was correct about
this so Andrew berry broke in in 2009 as
a scouting assistant with the Colts our
scouting assistant does not mean you're
a scout it means you're doing a lot of
cutting up tape you're probably doing a
lot of number crunching you might even
be doing things like organizing
schedules you know we were talking to
Scout yesterday that sit on the phone
and he said the same thing you know a
lot of these guys break in their booking
hotel rooms and flights I'm not saying
that's all Andrew Berry did but most
people break in in that then he became a
pro scout for the Colts so if you're a
pro scout you're evaluating current NFL
players you're looking at free agents
guys you can sign on the waiver wire so
you're not grinding it out you're not
going to Alabama Scout in the offensive
line you're not going to LSU scouting
Joe burrow you are looking at guys who
have already made it which no disrespect
it's a tough job it's a good job but it
is not road scouting for the draft is
very different from then he was promoted
to a pro scouting coordinator so pro
scouting coordinator for you guys who
haven't been behind the scenes that's
somebody who is going to be running a
lot of the nuts and bolts the
organizational side of things again not
on the road evaluating players and I'm
gonna keep hammering that point home to
andrew berry and I hope he does a great
job in Cleveland lord knows they need to
help but he has not been somebody that
is out on the road evaluating a lot of
this time was spent coordinating and in
the analytics side of things which is
very important to Cleveland then he
surfaces in Cleveland in 2016 2018 VP of
player personnel again not out on the
road scouting but working more on the
analytic side of things goes to Philly
for a year this past year excuse me same
title VP for Bob's a lot of analytics a
lot of coordination and now
the general manager of the Cleveland
Browns and I think there are some things
to applaud here and rubrics 32 years old
he's the youngest general manager in
football okay good job to you man that's
four years old younger than me and
you're a GM in the NFL that that
deserves some some applause he's done a
great job to get to this point and then
another thing is very important now he's
only the second african-american general
manager in the NFL something that we all
know has been a problem with minority
hire so kudos to Andrew berry like I
said I hope he turns it around but when
I say things like they don't have a
traditional Scout in the top end of the
decision-making process they don't Paul
DePodesta
I mean we all know he's a baseball guy
Andrew berry I mean he played college
football but he's more of an analytics
guy so if Elliot Wolfe is let go with
alonzo highsmith now out the Browns
don't have someone who is that guy that
you want to sit they don't have an IDI
dodge you guys have heard us talk about
him before trick kerchner Scott fitter
or some of that you're gonna send it on
the road to do a lot of the heavy
scouting they don't have that guy and
they're gonna need to find them as they
fill out this front office again once
again the Browns are hitting the reset
button so I don't think anybody should
be surprised about that now in Houston
we've been waiting for seems like a year
now for them to hire a general manager
there's a lot of talk that it might be
Nick Caesarea once his contract came up
with the New England Patriots that did
not happen
Nick Kesari oh they tried to get him
last summer turns out there's a clause
in his contract that he couldn't leave
so the Houston Texans roll through the
2019 season without a general manager
they pull off traits for Laremy Tunsil
they get Kenny Stills they ship Jadeveon
Clowney out and now they've just made it
official that Bill O'Brien is gonna be
the general manager as well as head
coach so if you want to talk about
control and an organization guys it is
Bill O'Brien he is the head coach he's
the general manager they fired their cap
guy so he's the cap guy now I mean this
is unchecked power the bill O'Brien has
in the Texas front office there's a lot
of trust for the ownership group to put
into him and I think for a Brian you
could say okay well you wheat he might
not be the most likable guy in the world
but he's won a lot of ballgames with the
Houston Texans his ability to develop
deshaun Watson probably saved his job
but this does feel like a little bit of
a make-or-break because if it doesn't
work it all comes down on Bill O'Brien
he's the only guy in the NFL who
actually has the title general manager
and head coach and we haven't seen that
in a long time where somebody actually
has it now you could say that I bill
part that Bill Belichick
excuse me he's the general manager but
he hasn't owned that title you could say
that Andy Reid has a lot of personnel
control he doesn't have the title Pete
Carroll same deal
Bill O'Brien the only guy who has a GM
title along with head coach which is
it's kind of amazing that he's the one
who is gonna break that mold you know it
kind of used to be this way Jimmie
Johnson Bill Parcells you know they
wanted to buy the groceries and cook the
meal was Bill Parcells famously said but
it really switched to where we didn't
have guys doing [ __ ] and we'll see
if it works with Bill O'Brien if so
there might be more people who are more
owners who are looking at this type of
setup of you have a guy who's been there
now six years he's had some success so
maybe you just want him running the
whole operation all right where to take
our first break we come back we're gonna
run you guys through some of the draft
rumors that I'm hearing some players
rising up my big board as we get into
draft season just a couple days away
after Super Bowl 54 you know we're going
pedal to the metal on the draft and then
we'll have Penn State heat or gross
meadows coming back right after this all
right we are back once again a solo show
today mellow is off educating the youth
of America
Connor is hopefully in bed drinking lots
of gatorade and getting some rest so I'm
chilling with the video guys here on
radio row in South Beach so if you're
watching on YouTube
yes it's awkward that I'm sitting here
staring into a camera by myself I feel
like the [ __ ] president giving a
fireside chat right now or I'm waiting
for someone to like come up behind me
and not realize I'm working you just
start talking to me that has happened
before so well if it does we'll just
roll with it we'll see what happens but
I wanted to run through some of the
things that we're hearing out in the
draft community this is kind of a dead
period because everything gets so
focused on what has happened in the NFL
with these two teams we're talking about
the Chiefs the Niners all week long it
feels like and you know the passing of
Kobe Bryant has affected a lot of this
too because a lot of the the focus as it
should in the sports media world has
shifted to Kobe and again as it should
so next week probably going to heat up
teams that aren't the Super Bowl right
now most of them are going to be in
Scouting meetings they're gonna get the
whole crew together after the Senior
Bowl and they're gonna run through the
tape they're gonna watch the game tape
they're gonna watch the practice tape
they're gonna run through their
interview notes and they're gonna start
to really truly stack the board when it
comes to the 2020 NFL Draft now you guys
know what that means when they start
stacking the board those Scouts get
bored they start talking to guys like me
so there should be a lot of information
coming out
in the next few weeks but some things
that I feel like are notable and one of
those it's the rise of Makai Beckton and
it has been we talked about it on the
show yesterday
Daniel Jeremiah great friend of the show
put backed in at number four overall and
kind of just rocked the draft world
there had already been some talk about
what he would be a first-round pick you
were starting to hear that heat up
starting to see it in some mock drafts
that back to him be a first-round pick
now it just seems like a foregone
conclusion that he's going to be a top
11 pick in the upcoming draft and I
mentioned it on Twitter I mentioned it
on previous shows I've spent a lot of
time trying to get caught up on game
film I was actually just talking to Jeff
Schwartz who spent a long time in the
NFL a good friend of ours and about the
fact that because of tailgate tour this
year kind of behind the eight-ball and
you find these moments where you get a
two or three day break to catch up on
film Christmas break was one of those
for me because you know we're not out on
the road working this past week in
between Senior Bowl and Super Bowl I had
two days where I could just sit and
watch tape and get caught up on players
and talk to people you talk to Scouts
talk to trainers and having that
opportunity Becton was the one guy
really zeroed in on because he was not
really on my radar as an underclassmen
of coming into this year so he wasn't
somebody that you're super evaluating
like Jedrek wills or like Andrew Thomas
so it was a little bit of a surprise so
there is a rise but it's not because
like anything he did the rise of bekhten
is more because no one was watching him
and paying attention to him as a draft
prospect at least in the media side of
things until kind of late in the process
once he declared once that January 20
deadline goes by four guys to go back to
school you got a chance to watch and say
okay this guy's he's pretty special to
be as big as he is it at 6-3 I'm anxious
excuse me it's six foot seven I'm
anxious to see what he actually weighs
in it he's listed at 370 I think he'll
probably be down from that one of the
actual combine rolls around but I'll
take my comparison for him was Bryant
McKinney and my notes are he's huge but
moves like a smaller guy a basketball
player with balance and body control
great hand accuracy and he's very very
strong as a point of attack
something we've been talking around the
show for years is that the NFL is
getting smaller on defense because you
want speed you look at Kansas City look
at San Francisco you need speed to keep
up with those guys
now offenses are coming back and
countering that with size and power and
back then is perfect for that so don't
be surprised if like DJ put it I don't
know they B's me the number four pick
but
wouldn't be surprised if he's a top 11
pick and I say 11 because that's where
the New York Jets are and that's where
we expect the run on tackles to kind of
inch now another thing that I've been
hearing a lot over the past couple of
weeks really is that we should expect
five quarterbacks to be drafter than the
top 15
now you might listen to that and say
that sounds like a smoke screen from a
team drafting outside the top 15 that
they want quarterbacks to go early
because it will push more good players
down to them and I'm not disagreeing
with that especially here we are in
almost early February there's a lot of
smoke out there and a lot of teams are
still trying to figure this draft class
out so I think with this noise it could
just be that but when you look at the
draft order the Bengals are gonna take a
quarterback at one the Dolphins will
probably take a one at five the Chargers
at six the Panthers could at seven the
Raiders technically could at 12 the
Colts at 13 the Buccaneers at 14 there
are a lot of teams that need
quarterbacks and while we can look at
this class and say all right it's Joe
burrow as a franchise quarterback and
then there's a gap because there's
questions about to his health his
questions about Justin Herbert's touch
and his ability to get through reads
there's questions about it jordan loves
turnovers and level competition
questions about jacob east and with
limited film and the fact that he
couldn't beat out a guy like Jake Fromm
so there are a lot of questions out
there but when you look at the class and
the amount of needs I don't think it
should be a surprise for anyone we'll
see what four agencies gonna have a huge
impact on this where does tom brady go
where's Phillip Rivers go what happens
with Cam Newton
what does Drew Brees decide to do so
there's me a lot of dominoes that have
to fall for five quarterbacks doing the
top 15 but it is absolutely possible do
we see that run all quarterbacks now two
players who are moving up the board for
me and I hate to use that expression
because it's there it's just that you're
getting to see them more and you're more
properly rating them it's not like they
have done anything to necessarily rise
this time of year but one is Kyle Duggar
the safety from lenoir-rhyne who we got
a chance to watch at the Senior Bowl
last week and he was someone who I
actually waited to watch a lot of game
tape on because I didn't want my first
impression of him to be basically at d3
level football I wanted to see him
against power five teams and when you
watched him you know the few games I did
watch of him at lenoir-rhyne
he looked like a guy that might have to
move to linebacker he was just so much
bigger stronger and faster than a lot of
the players that he was seeing but then
we get him down to mobile and he played
a lot he played safety all week
also returned punts I mean he really
showed off his athleticism I had
questions about his ability to really
sink his hips and open up and run he did
that all week long a mobile though so I
think when you look at Kyle Duggar he's
made the case to be a mid second round
pick you could probably put him in there
I think Xavier McKinney he's kind of on
an island by himself then you have grant
Delpit Ashton Davis who was hurt and
didn't get to go at the Senior Bowl and
then I would put Kyle Duggar in there
now he's gonna be someone scheme
specific because he is almost like a
strong saftey you know he's almost like
a throwback type safety who could walk
up and play some linebacker but he truly
did look like a special player in Mobile
and because it's mock draft season I
have a seven or mock draft coming up
Monday morning when you start to do a
mock draft it's funny because you have
all these players that you really like
and you think this guy's a top 30 player
this guy's top 50 player and you start
to do the mock draft and you realize
that some guys go much earlier than you
expected and some guys go much later
well the one player who I always find is
in the top 35 picks is Cesar Ruiz from
Michigan and I'm not afraid to say he's
my top-rated interior offensive lineman
in this class at this point I think he's
a damn good center very agile he's tough
in space he's good at the point of
attack
so all season we talked about creed
Humphrey well he goes back to Oklahoma
Tyler be a dish really struggled this
past year Nick Harris is a pretty small
guy coming out of Washington so when you
watch the Michigan tape Ruiz is just
absolutely dominating people in the Big
Ten in a pretty good football conference
so if you're a team like my team the
49ers who might be looking for a center
because of Western Rick Berg's injury
you know the Chiefs could be looking at
center a lot of teams late first round
could be looking to fix a hole in their
interior offensive line for me Ruiz is
the top guy in this class all right
fellows take one more break we come back
we have two more break excuse me I can't
count today two more breaks we come back
we've got you to Grosse Meadows Penn
State pass rusher joining us here live
radio row in Miami Beach we promised you
guys awesome interviews all week long
and I I'm gonna be honest I've been
saying your name wrong all year I bet so
will you just get it put it on the
record for me yeet or gross mottos okay
I've been sent my toes yeah either
everyone says that when they say like
eat or they just silent yeah I can see
that we need to give you a good nickname
like a good strong nickname make it easy
and right before we started rolling we
were talking about you as a draft
prospect
since that's my job if you it guys and
you want to know where I had you ranks I
said I'm a big fan because you know link
size not a lot of guys like you
have you watched anyone like Brian burns
from last year and thought like okay I'm
kind of like that guy and he went 15
overall or is there anyone that you've
kind of tried to model your game after
from last year or any years you know Mac
that's fine you know you say I already
like Bradley Chuck like like the way he
was building like I used he's a citizen
so I was really a big fan of his since
probably my freshman girl in college and
I was so if I had to compare myself to
anyone I probably be hit I mean it's
pretty good he was a pretty good Ricky
here so that's a good pick what is it
like being at Penn State where you're up
against such great competition every day
now I've talked guys that like you know
Alabama LSU or they're like you know the
drop off tour that from the NFL to bamas
not that difference Penn State I mean
you've seen guys like say Quan Berkeley
my Sanders some really good players and
what do you think that I mean yeah if
you've tackled those guys in practice
you're probably going to be okay in the
NFL yeah like those guys like there's
just certain players I feel like it's
just not something you see every day so
being like going on to the next stage
and I feel like everybody's gonna be
like that guy so it's good it's like
there's be 11 sake one who's the
toughest tackle you've gone against the
big teams known for running the ball I
probably say the tackle from Michigan
run you name 75 yeah yeah yeah he's
pretty good yeah yeah his dad played I
don't know if you're old enough to
remember his dad I said that I told
someone that evidence that was there was
pretty great but yeah Michigan Ohio
State and you've gone against some of
the best of us Iowa has some good guys
if I remember right was it last year you
guys did you play when I was 18 I played
them all three years yeah and that you
might be the reason their left tackles
going back to college because he was
like no I'm not ready I was saying in
college instead of going to the draft
and you had a field day against two
players that headed into this year
people were talking about they might
both be first rounders yeah and you had
a pretty good day two years in a row
yeah I mean those guys are phenomenal
but you know I just sometimes
you could be honest you humble me
sometimes when the better the match hug
those guys got a lot of respect from you
it was really good yeah you can I see
you being humble like man I don't want
to get in trouble it's only my first day
at yarrow I'm not trying to start [ __ ]
we actually got Cody Ford and Charles a
mini Hugh to like beef on Twitter last
year with these interviews so it might
be our guy we might get you an allergy
Jackson go
what type of Dean do you think you are
for our listeners and viewers who
haven't had a chance to watch you play a
lot how would you classify yourself I
mean are you an outside the tackle guy
or you versatile what type of player do
you think you are I think I'm very
versatile you know you used me pretty
much anywhere along the front I think
you know I'm someone plays I real
physical I like to get like not a lot of
space so I mean I think as far as like
Russian wise you could put me like any
position on front line and I could find
a way to be effective yeah you're still
young right I mean how old are you I'm
21
yeah so your baby stuff is that
something that as you've been training
for the draft are you paying attention
to you know that balance between how
much you weigh and how strong you are
but also wanting to be quick and fast
for the combine absolutely you know I've
been putting on I put on about 10 pounds
so far I'm not sure where I'm gonna go
into the combine app but I'm still
feeling fast to feel like I can move
pretty well so I'm not not really
worried about my weight at the moment
what types of things you doing a
training is it a lot more like three
cone prep or you doing more position
specific stuff working on pass-rush
moves it's really a combination like
absolutely play it's really 5050 in
terms of like combination of like
working on like how to run and that type
of stuff versus the precision work now I
have to ask you because I think everyone
asked you about this
you obviously have a really unique story
of you know losing your brother I have
three brothers I can't even imagine and
then also losing your father when you
were really young how much of that I
mean do you still carry with you on a
day-to-day basis where I mean you picked
your number after after your brother
right for life so how much of that is
with you every day and what would that
moment be like when you hear your name
you know that they're not here with you
but that they're gonna be a big part of
that moment yeah I mean I feel like for
me personally like they're part of
everything I'll do you know like every
decision I make I know that they I like
watching over me and I just shot like
carry myself in a way that I make them
proud with everything I do and you know
I feel like when I go out there that
night not to hear my name called I feel
like they will be with me like in spirit
so I feel good and one question that
every team is gonna ask you I'm sure
you're ready for this is you know what
are your parents do was your upbringing
like and you're you check those boxes
just fine right I mean both parents you
know high cards are people you've never
been in any kind of trouble
and your parents are both police
officers is that right they were police
officers not anymore but that's how they
met yeah yeah I've read a couple
articles about you so no I mean but that
is a big part of it so yeah I think you
know your agent will have you ready for
this but being able to say like no I
come from a good family you don't have
to worry about that it's just another
selling point for you as a player great
friend you know my dad still works my
mom actually just started teaching and
my older sisters actually the gym
teacher at my old high school so I mean
everyone's doing real well for
themselves and yeah and then there's you
yeah real soon you mentioned the draft
what do you what are your plans I mean
you gonna if you get invited to Vegas
you're gonna go do the thing are you
gonna hang out with family what what's
your what's your idea of what draft
night will be for you I mean if I have
you seen this stage it's on water yeah
so I know if that was real it's real
yeah man I don't know though I have you
on like a jet ski or something to the
stage it would be cool that would be
safe but if if you get that opportunity
your that's something you thought about
like you got to be there absolutely
why is that for I mean I top-down High
School you can pray tell by looking at
the difference between me and you but
what is it about that moment of being on
that stage I supposed to hanging out
with your family at home is it just like
the spectacle of it all I mean I guess
so like you grew up watching that as
like like that's kind of something like
like I want to be like those guys that's
that's the position I want to be in so I
got the opportunity to do it I mean I
ball over yeah and you get to hug Roger
Goodell yeah
pretty cool this Super Bowl obviously is
a lot about the pass rushers you know
there's Nick bow so there's Frank Clark
when you look at those the way those
guys are built in the way these teams
are built is that something that you
feel cuz you're gonna get asked at the
combine you know what how do how do you
fit into our scheme you feel like you're
like those guys and that you can do a
little bit of everything uh yeah I feel
like we're we're different you know some
ways obviously but in terms of like
versatility I feel like I'm similar you
know and the things that I can do on the
field whether it's in space or on the
line so yeah now chase young obviously
came back to play against you guys this
year after his little little time off
yeah you've been on the other side of
the field from him but when you look at
chase Young who everybody is in love
with in this year's class what
differences do you see between your game
and his I mean he's a phenomenal
phenomenal football player and he just
gets a lot of lot of opportunities you
know gets a field I mean he just make
stuff happen I mean I do just a
playmaker yeah how do you go at someone
like that or like yourself like if you
were on if you were playing offense for
a day yeah okay we got a we got to go
chase young or you gotta go at yourself
or chase on it LSU how do you go with a
guy like that I mean I could talk from
personal experience like there's no time
that he should not have been double-team
at all times
yeah and you see Nick Bosa in the NFL
right now basically doing the same thing
you did at Ohio State so how excited are
you man for just the next this week's
gonna be fun
but then after that you jump right back
into the grind because the combine is
like three weeks from now yeah I mean I
mean I've had a lot of fun since I've
been out here but I've been really
focused at the same time really taking
advantage I feel like I'm improved I'm a
Philly I'm ready I'm gonna blow it out
got you doing everything at the combine
right as of right now yeah yeah I like
that I like it when guys are just
confident I'm gonna go in and be
competitive I do have to ask you though
who you pickin in the Super Bowl Chiefs
or Niners now you know how I feel every
day I feel like I'm going to
with the 14 others that's not what I
expected everybody to pick the chief
sees other homes and any people I like
defense right I'm a Niners fan so I'm
glad to hear it there we go all right
man thank you so much for your time
enjoy South Beach and we'll see it the
combine dude all right thank you
appreciate it
all right guys that is our show for
today thanks again either gross Matos
for coming by the show definitely
looking forward to seeing him throughout
this draft process and thanks again for
setting us up here at Radio route to our
amazing video and audio people we will
be back tomorrow Friday morning we'll
have a show for you and then Saturday
afternoon don't forget sitting down with
Kenny Vaccaro that episode will come out
Monday so a lot of good stick to
football coming to you over the next
couple days make sure you hit that
subscribe button on Apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast for Connor
and the crew we'll talk to y'all real
soon